most of america's lifting coveted
restrictions one of the world's biggest
cities has been shut down shanghai home
to about 25 million people is largely at
a standstill today as china battles its
worst wave of covet infections since the
start of this global pandemic in 2020
lucy kraft explains how this lockdown
has raised questions about china's
so-called zero-covid strategy
shanghai's lockdown was supposed to last
just a few days rolled out in stages to
minimize disruption but that plan has
been abandoned and now most of shanghai
china's largest and wealthiest city has
been shut down with no telling when life
could get back to normal
shanghai's modern streets have been
transformed into a post-apocalyptic
landscape
residents have been barricaded into
their homes allowed out only for covid
testing even infants are being screened
residents aren't allowed to walk their
dogs the only canines permitted on city
streets are robots broadcasting
anti-infection tips
frustration is so widespread over panic
buying and persistent food shortages it
inspired a rap song
[Music]
american sean ryan lives in shanghai is
there any sense at all that this is
overkill that the zero covet strategy
maybe has worn out its usefulness that
there should be a more flexible approach
i think there are a lot of people in
shanghai who are saying you know right
now the medicine is worse than the
disease we have people who are dying
because they can't get access to medical
care how many people have actually died
from this recent surge of kovid and the
government has told us zero
it's unclear how long shanghai's mass
lockdown will last residents are bracing
for possibly weeks of home confinement
but despite the strain on residents
china vows it will maintain its zero
covenant policy
lucy kraft cbs mornings tokyo